the scene more than 24 hours on of a
tragedy that unfolded in a matter of
minutes just after lunchtime on
Christmas Eve a nine-year-old British
girl somehow got into difficulties while
swimming in an unsupervised pool at this
popular Spanish resort it's believed
that first her 16 year old brother
and then her 52 year old father jumped
into the water to try to rescue her but
soon all three family members were in
serious trouble emergency services were
called but by the time they arrived all
three were found unresponsive in the
water club Lacoste a world on the Costa
del Sol has 21 swimming pools at the
resort some bigger than others but
Spanish poolside regulations mean a
lifeguard is only required when a pool
is bigger than 200 meters squared
slightly smaller than the size of a
tennis court one of the resort's
lifeguards who didn't want to be named
spoke to Sky News do you think that if
there was a lifeguard there yesterday
the three people would be alive many of
the other pools on the site are deserted
guests are too scared to take a dip
Dennis and his family come to this
resort three times a year he's been a
member of this club for over two decades
you know how does this happen anywhere
but when this really hits home when
you're here you know it really is a
struggle but taken really I mean it's
just on your mind so you woke up this
morning so you wake up he's on your mind
you know so yeah it's gonna go on for a
few days both say your hearts with the
families really and um you know that
what they must feel like I read that
note terrible absolutely terrible CL Sea
World resorts say the Spanish
authorities carried out a full
investigation which found no concern in
relation to the pool where these people
died they say this was just a tragic
accident
this is a family who went on a holiday
promising escape from the British winter
weather but now the mother who's
believed to have raised the alarm is
receiving specialist care from Spanish
authorities before she comes back to the
UK in sermon rasheed Sky News